ou encore quand nous on 29 décembre 2012
la température est agréable comme vous
pouvez le constater les gens sourire
facile on est encore sur le boss des
premières neiges ça commence à sentir
noël il 23 heures je me réveille je m'en
vais accomplir mon honneur de voir de
commis de nuit dans un couche-tard pour
une quatrième nuit consécutive leur
grève avec un grand r la passion à
grains coup de sac de chips toute
bouteille colombe de liga flatte mais
sentiment d'accomplissement profond
quand on balance notre caisse à la fin
de notre nuit de pur bonheur
enfin avoir l'impression de servir à
quelque chose
travailler de nuit c'est assister à
l'éveil de la noirceur pendant que la
lumière d'or si le côtoyer l'humain dans
ses plus bas fonds les nuits les
couteaux volent bas il est 4 heures du
matin quand lula pas j'en vois un
sourire je le reconnais est un habitué
bien sûr avant de ces bouteilles de la
nuit marry me chante son dernier hit les
red bull sont en spéciale 2 pour capter
il m'a toujours pas sourire s'approche à
moins d'un port rapide trop rapide alors
que j'allais temps dire quoi que ce soit
une saisie par le bras fermement
on se regarde droit dans les yeux et
c'est son rouge est paniquée la bave sur
les com / de ses élèves
il sent la détresse pour à combien s'est
vite qu'ils tiennent seringues massa
mais libre ils approchent dangereusement
de nombreux films dit donne moi le cash
je te donne les sides vous vous je me
rappelais de ces moules toute ma vie
mais je me suis donc exécuté attendre en
comprendre j'ai donné l'argent de la
caisse j'ai même proposé d'en faire
autant avec le contenu du coffre fort un
service à la clientèle
ils reprochaient logo pris l'argent qui
est parti aussi vite qu'ils étaient
entrés disparu dans la nuit qui connaît
cette roumi la porte claque
marie-mai va commencer son dernier
refrain les red bull sont toujours en
spéciale j'étais maman très calme voire
peser de malgré ce qui vient de se passe
je prendrai ce délit puis je décide
d'aller m'asseoir ans maria de mon
comptoir kf
il faut mieux pourquoi j'ai regardé ni
même pendant un bon 60 secondes
j'ai bougé je les tournées joli regard
des près j'ai regardé dehors et j'ai
compris à ce moment là que je contrôlais
mémé donc je contrôlais mon corps donc
que je contrôlais ma tête donc que
j'étais vivant je me suis levé de bouger
lever les yeux de mes mains dit désolé
pour les arrêts sensationnels dire
textuellement l'énergie des années je
suis demandé mais qu'est ce que chaque
année six prisonniers derrière le
comptoir de ma job inutiles et stériles
fraîchement victime d'un hold up à la
sereine porteuses du vih
j'ai vieilli qu'une renaissance tout
simplement j'ai immédiatement compris à
ce moment là que je t'ai pas au bon
endroit puis je l'avais toujours aussi
dans le fond j'ai pas dans une situation
parents qui me permettait de dépasser
d'apprendre de rayonner et surtout de
m'amuser
alors pourquoi gaspiller mon temps
depuis la fin du secondaire une carte de
mode
depuis cinq secondes bac que je me
battais contre le temps entre un vrai
travail est ce que j'aimais le plus fort
au monde la musique j'ai décidé que c'en
était terminé de penser j'ai quitté mon
emploi le matin même
j'ai tout de suite trouvé ma nouvelle
résolution pour l'année qui arrive est
assez rapidement une tonne par jour
démocratiquement
arrêter maintenant par jour ça me
semblait logique
paris n'a jamais occupé aucun autre
emploi que la musique
ah oui j'allais aussi composer réalisé à
ranger produit et mixé et publier
gratuitement sur internet
une nouvelle tonnes par jour pendant 1
365 tonnes en 365 jours et je suis fier
de dire que je les fais
tu fais ce que j'aime le plus faire au
monde à chaque jour j'ai rencontré des
gens extraordinaires j'ai travaillé avec
des personnes qui ont marqué l'histoire
des génies des enfants des gens que
j'admirais musicalement des inconnus
surtout de views m
j'ai vécu ma pire ami de toute ma vie
mais j'ai surtout vécu la meilleure
année toute ma vie j'ai eu des gros bas
et surtout d'énormes pots j'ai composé
des taux n'a oublié celle de 25 minutes
et j'ai surtout composer des chansons
que je qualifie d' inoubliable
essai est loué
tout ça j'ai réussi ma résolution de
l'année
aujourd'hui presque un an après la fin
de ce projet fou je peux vous affirmer
avec fierté que j'occupe l'emploi que je
rêvais d'avoir quand j'avais 15 ans je
mange à ma faim je vis dans un palace je
voyage où je veux pour le plaisir du
voyage pour le travail je travaille sur
des projets qui mordent extrêmement fier
j'ai un chien et je fais de la musique
une par jour ça m'a permis de rencontrer
une tonne de gens que j'aurais jamais
rencontré savait pas été de ce projet
quand je parle aux gens on a bien
souvent parler de ce qui fonde en vie
puis de fil en aiguille je leur demande
s'ils aiment leur job vous seriez
surpris du nombre de personnes qui
répondent par oui à cette question la
réponse qui viennent le plus souvent
c'est bon ou le classer mois puis quand
les gens me demandent ce que moi je fais
plus qui leur dit que j'adore ma job et
leur réaction est trop souvent la même
très très chanceux
tu es chanceux mais quelle phrase
ridicule
non mais c'est vrai comment est ce qui
est possible de penser que la chance
d'avoir dans le bonheur au travail
heureusement pour les gens qui pensent
et ni pour un petit peu je suis ici
aujourd'hui pour vous présenter ce qui
guide ma vie depuis le 1er janvier 2013
ce qui m'a permis de m'ouvrir les yeux
fait un petit guide là il ya quatre cinq
six chapitres j'ai appelé ça un jour par
jour un jour par jour c'est quoi grosso
modo c'est de choisir un objectif à
réaliser en une pixie consacré à chaque
jour mais comment est ce que je fais
pour trouver un objectif vous expliquer
c'est super simple la première chose qui
vous vient en fait j'ai envie de faire
du prix moyen par jour
j'ai envie d'écrire un livre un chapitre
par jour forex broyage mais une ville
par jour vraiment que j'arrête de fumer
et pas de club par jour j'aurais
vraiment envie de travailler une nuit
dans un dépanneur
personne ne veut savoir
un jour c'est quoi on s'obstine europe
os et 24 heures 48 demi-heure 96 quart
d'heure mille quatre cent quarante
minutes et 86400 secondes on vit en
moyenne selon la toile du québec le
canadien moyen une espérance de vie
moyenne de 80 81 mathématiquement si
vingt neuf mille deux cents jours j'ai
fait des effects et madame ben 9200 gros
ex rouges sur notre gros calendrier de
la vie comme les baleines bleues tandis
que les éphémères c'est une magnifique
bibitte vives de trois à quatre jours
vous étiez une éphémère mais samedi vous
en seriez présentement vos derniers
instants sur la terre est ce que votre
vie en aurait valu la peine soyez vous
cette suite ce que vous avez fait depuis
samedi la vie au la vie c'est notre
premier point commun un ça nous
entourent constamment depuis notre
naissance tout vie lézarder au 10 mai
les animaux les nuages les nuages les
nuages
j'ai trop longtemps cru que c'était
comme une énorme tapisserie qui se
répétaient à l'infini sûrement d'aller à
3 g banaliser les nuages comme si
j'avais oublié que l'eau que je bois
chaque jour s'est évaporée on voyage et
des centaines de kilomètres à des
milliers de pieds d'altitude en créant
des formes magnifique pour aller nourrir
un autre organisme vivant la vie c'est
faire confiance à sa propre naissance
sap est sonnée clichés ce que je veux
dire mais c'est vrai quand on tombe on
prend deux minutes pour avoir mal ce
correct c'est normal on est tombé on se
relève
on rame ans notre jetpack pieuvre
d'école sans échec pas de succès et
aucun comparatif pour savoir qu'on a
réussi
deuxième point la mort opérant la mort
ça c'est notre deuxième point commun à
caen on va tous passer qu'on veuille ou
non c'est plate mais bon c'est pas
commun sait pas quand ça va nous arriver
c'est parfait comme ça s'agite du
challenge une grande partie de la
motivation naveen vient du fait que la
mort et que
j'ai pas envie de gaspiller ma présence
sur la glace la mort fait penser mais
pas trop non plus parce que ça va
toujours rester gullo que pippo l'fun
mais un petit mémo 30 ans fait
aujourd'hui bien le temps qu'on se verra
condor 8 heures en moyenne 13 dans mon
coeur quel individu moyen travail de 9 à
5 dont twitter
ça nous laisse un dernier tiers des 8
heures pour vaquer à nos autres besoins
occupation loisirs donc grosso modo dodo
travail temps libre ou vtt l1 qui
n'aiment pas les acronymes toujours à
était infiniment pratique le dodo c'est
un intouchable
il va toujours finir par s'imposer qu'on
le veuille ou non c'est aussi la
solution miracle à tous les problèmes
fatigué initial marabout une sieste est
prise une sieste une sieste une sieste
le travail le travail c'est primordial
mais il faut faire attention de bien
faire la différence entre le travail est
un travail le travail c'est un état
d'esprit et un travail est une
obligation
une obligation qui nous suit depuis la
maternelle
le premier emploi de tous les enfants un
huit heures par jour qui va nous suivre
bien longtemps nous amène à notre
dernier tiers temps les états libres
selon moi c'est la période la plus
importante de nos johnny si trop souvent
négligé par le sua tendance à servir la
période tampon entre les deux os c'est
faux prophètes pour publier que les
talibans c'est le seul instant restant
dans notre journée qui nous
appartiennent vraiment donc à ne pas
négliger
ceci votre journée titre est et restera
pour le restant de votre vie que vous
vouliez ou non
c'est ancré dans notre système
d'exploitation l'enfant ce que j'ai
remarqué c'est qu'on a tendance à voir
l'enfant confus comme une autre personne
distinctes ceci est une erreur à éviter
à tout prix ce truc que j'ai trouvé le
pourrait pas tomber dans ce piège s est
de recouper plein de photos de moi qui
date de ma naissance à aujourd'hui
puis de les parcourir en prenant le
temps de penser que de regarder chaque
détail
chaque souvenir de chaque photo nous
sommes aujourd'hui l'enfant d'une ou de
2034 faut jamais ridiculiser les rêves
les ambitions les projets qu'on ait eue
quand on était plus jeunes
ça fait partie intégrante de notre
personnalité quand est-ce qu'on devient
un adulte on devient adulte quand on
arrête d'imaginer qu'on oublie l'enfant
sur le travail le travail c'est
primordial c'est ce qui est à la base du
sentiment de devoir accompli que je
crois un licenciement qui fait le plus
de bien à chanter c'est important de
travailler fort oui mais surtout de
travailler bien quand on sait qu'on est
plus productif ou qu'on est désintéressé
par notre job depuis un trop long boudin
mais il faut prendre des vacances
prenez des vacances c'est pas mal de
prendre du temps pour soi faut arrêter
de se culpabiliser pas normal qu'on
prenne 4 % de vacances par anne richard
branson mon grade jeune pdg de virgin
faisait des courses david michôd benson
le pdg jean a statué que ces employés
pouvaient partir en vacances quand ils
le voulaient plus nombreux tant qu'il
voulait pas que son âge au dans leur
échéancier ou leur projet dit qu'il
n'est ce pas là une idée simple et
totalement génial vous imaginez vous la
motivation vous avez quand vous venez au
travail après vos vacances disons que
vous avez pris des vacances vous venez à
votre travail puis vous aimez toujours
pas ça mais quitter votre job trouvez
vous un emploi vous allez 1 me en habit
centaines de militants si vous en
trouvez pas mais créer votre job depuis
l'âge de 6 et 13 ans j'ai commencé à
écrire une liste de job que j'ai voulu
que je veux faire ma première job
j'avais 6 ans cela est évident georges
qui a protesté le camion pas compliqué
puis tout au fil des années mais j'ai
dit j'ai ajouté des professions
simplement scandale fans avec cette
liste là c'est que tu peux toujours
ajouter des emplois mais jamais en
enlever à quoi ça sert
mais ça s'est rassis qui posent des
questions sur ton travail tu as juste à
ouvrir ton petit carnet regardez les
jobs est là dedans si la job que tu fais
et bada mais tu sais que tu rentrais de
mentir à soi même parce que c'est toi
qui les écrit cette liste existe une
profession de rêve pour tout le monde
je vais conclure heures charline suite
ou en français court et d'où ce que vous
aimez faire à chaque jour tout
simplement attendait pas de survivre un
crash d'avion ou de voir le dopé à ce
ring il suffit de plonger tête première
la vie est trop courte
nous sommes aujourd'hui en 2014 1998 est
tous prêts nous que 2030
le futur c'est aujourd'hui je crois
sincèrement que le bonheur n'est pas un
luxe c'est un choix